last time I talked to you you're about
to ready to hop into that ring yeah I'm
sorry I couldn't get the W man I I know
I trust me I realize I suck if that's
what you're gonna say go for it
Oh fine in fact I want to know whether
or not there's a rematch in the horizon
with KS ah I doubt it if I I don't know
maybe maybe down the line I got kind of
want to do MMA boxing boxing stuff me
there's a lot of rules I'm not really a
guy who like rules or is it good at
following them so yeah the next next
next time I fight it'll be a little more
a little more free free flow probably
hopefully in the cage but you know you
did tell me that boxing was an outlet
for you though it really kind of turned
your life around a little boxing boxing
saved my life like I will never ever
forget that by the way I love this sport
to be honest I wish I could stop but
like some about some of our hitting pads
is extremely cathartic and it's so much
more fun to me than working out you know
I don't like pushing weights is is is
pointless what do you wish waits for a
physique and aesthetic to look good like
when you challenge yourself man in the
show
speaking of challenges Jake any chance
he's gonna take on ksi in the boxing man
yes yes so Jake's gonna got a fight
coming up with this this dude named Gib
he's gonna be give and then he's gonna
be ksi and then at that point maybe
maybe to be every mess or do ksi and I
be like we might be doing bigger better
things for that boy it's just a good
storyline you know we'd love to be
entertained yeah real quick 20 19
obviously was a big year fewer ups and
downs what are you leaving behind this
beer a lot a lot a lot of ups a lot not
a lot of downs but that the down was a
big one and it's the loss I think I
think it's just uh
it's just that confidence that I I
always knew I had and the belief in
myself day it will get better like like
broke losing a fight in front of
millions of people isn't the easiest
thing ever but I've lost on a bigger
scale before and you know if I survive
that I could survive anything
[Music]